avec nous maintenant sophie brochu pdg
d'hydro-québec bonsoir madame brochu
l'ensemble c'est fini madame rochât une
fois qu'on prend acte du résultat dans
le maine il se passe quoi à partir de
maintenant est ce que la prochaine étape
c'est la contestation en cour par par
hydro plupart synchro green power
mais en fait est ce qu'on voit en france
et qu on va certainement défendre les
droits acquis qui sont issus de
l'obtention de tous les permis de
construction
requis de l'état du maine et du fédéral
est d'ailleurs la construction a
commencé et déjà quelques mois dans les
droits acquis sont bien réels on va
aller en cours pour faire valoir ces
droits là non pas pour contester la
légalité du processus un de
l'initiative citoyens le processus est
tout à fait légale mais ce qu'on veut
protester c'est la légalité du projet de
loi qui propose et qui qui fait fi d'un
fonds de tout ce qui s'est passé au
cours des derniers mois c'est ce qu'on
va faire au cours des prochains mois
juste pour bien comprendre le centro de
manpower il y avait un comité d'action
qui menait le programme de l'avant qui
contestent la constitutionnalité du
référendum vous n'êtes pas là
non en fait il écoutait et 2 je dois
vous dire que d'ailleurs présentement on
est en train l'a conçu mais nous non en
ce sens pour cette initiative qui est
citoyenne et où on pense que c'est un
cédant chasser dans dans la dans la loi
du monde puis ils peuvent ils peuvent
faire ça on va contester c'est le fait
que le projet de loi
qu'il tente de
communiquer est quelque chose qui est
illégal parce que encore une fois
sacrifié de tout un processus qui lui
est en syndication de règles de droit on
est là dedans puis comme les entreprises
qui produisent l'électricité à partir
d'énergies fossiles sont sont très très
riches qui ont fait ça depuis des lunes
ans on voit avec l'autre accoudé
jonction c'est un peu comme un jeu de
serpents et échelles cette histoire-là
secrets ses traits d'un simple des
délais mais on pense on pense que le bon
sens légal va prévaloir au bout de
toujours encore une fois les citoyens
peuvent peuvent faire ce qui est
désirade et qu'on fait que ceux là
gouverneur du maine john smith soutient
le projet est ce qu elle peut intervenir
pour dire d'accord le référendum c'est
un rejet du projet mais nous le maine
ont fait de projet quand même
été composé une question qui est
hypothétique faut pas m'en vouloir parce
que l'on est en vendant la légalité de
la position du gouverneur et gouverneur
a été très elle est d'abord de 104 est
posée qui soutient très fort le projet
qui laisse aller les processus et qui
par le passé imposer certains métaux
dans l'école suel il va je pense tu vas
savoir qu'on aille devant les cours
théoriquement la gouverneur doit au bout
de 30 jours après cet événement l'a
entériné le projet doit moitié des
contestations donc au cours des
prochains 30 jours encore une fois je
pense que nos opposants vont mettre une
injonction pour barrière de construire
avant le 30 jours puis nous on veut
imposer on va demander les gens sont en
situation illégale on s'en va pour
certains ok on comprend que vous en
élèves en cours ce projet l'oeil pour
fermer vous l'abandonnez pas on n'est
pas là non quand on regarde
la carte du projet c'était nuit monsieur
avant finalement sen pas fonctionné puis
on va le voir on va le voir là dedans
dans un instant après ça il ya celui du
maine là il ya de l'eau dans le gaz si
vous me permettez l'expression
mais il ya d'autres états qui s'appelle
le vermont et l'état de new york et avec
l'état de new york vous avez une ligne
un projet la petite en train de se
dessiner vers new york et ce quoi est ce
que vous pourriez retourne à la table à
dessin qui a passé par le vermont où par
new york
écoutez d'avoir le projet new york il
vise la desserte de la ville de lille
mais quand j'essaie d'amener le
massachusetts touche à l'état new york
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir un
raccordement est pris c'est un projet
hypothétique c'est vraiment pathétique
que c'est pas parce que je vous cache un
projet secret lors des phases finales on
est vraiment des terrains et qu'il ya 4
5 millions d'investis dans mes mains
sont amassés sur la foi des prix des
permis qui nous ont été octroyés alors
le plan c'est d'aller de l'avant et de
faire valoir sur cette loco
pays si cher parce que parce que c'est
la trace est dans cette mouvance
noyalais l'état du massachusetts aussi
qui est qui qui tente désespérément de
convaincre tout le monde des mérites du
projet donc j'ai vraiment beaucoup de
monde à secrétaire d'état à l'énergie du
gouvernement américain fédéral s'est
prononcé en faveur du projet alors
encore une fois je ne diminue pas la
capacité de certains citoyens humaine de
vouloir autre chose je pense que pour le
futur ce qu'ils ont fait pour le futur
pour fonctionner mais pour le passé on
ne peut pas réécrire une histoire
surtout pas dans les gares pas perdre
tous ses investissements alors
présentement notre plan c'est d'aller au
bout du processus légal puis on passe
vraiment que le bon sens ok mais entre
vous et moi est-ce que accessoires
éventuellement si ça marche pas il ya un
plan b passé par le vermont passer par
new york
écouter présente justement colada
monsieur fillion [ __ ] plan b sur quatre
soit 5,6 est là mais quand tu arrives
dans la vraie vie béante sur deux contre
un fait que je participe et epci pas
parce que je veux
avant le land de voix là on est vraiment
sûr sur le projet du mail puis si
d'aventuré on ne devait on ne veut pas
avoir raison mais on verra mais je suis
convaincu que le bon sens légal auprès
vraiment parce que c'est tellement
partant c'est tellement évident
maintenant vous rendez vous avez vous
chez hydro québec et je terminais là
dessus quelque chose que vous auriez
mais faire autrement peut-être mieux
pour que la populaire adhèrent davantage
à votre projet absolument jamais
monsieur quelques potes parler ni
monsieur parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu
pandémie j'aurais été aux mains à toutes
les semaines qui j'aurais fait ce que
j'ai fait avec les équipes dans les
dernières semaines où on réunissait
légende à coups de 5,10 autour d'une
table de cuisine où on réponde à des
questions très rigide tient et où les
gens nous disaient mon dieu mais
commence on ne savait possible alors on
ait été empêchée d'aller faire des
rencontres bernabeu viennent pour
répondre aux questions et aux prix est
d'ailleurs carton fini c'est ça et qu'on
leur demandait la ride et nous donnaient
leur aide imaginez ça aurait pu faire ça
dans les vingt derniers mois on en
serait pas là mais on est là où on est
et on rejoue et les cas qui nous ont été
données puis on a confiance en dessin
faut rester calmes puis faut être
patient c'est pas ma force mais je vais
dire ce parfait quand même vous avez pas
trop le choix merci beaucoup sophie
brochu au plaisir c'est pourquoi de
studio 1 gérard davet vous voir chez
vous vous serez la bienvenue merci à lui
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d